hello habeas corpus today we're gonna be
discussing the true story of Colonel
Sanders
do you have any booze 3me Harland
David Sanders at the age of 13 he's like
I love education but I asked to look
after my family
yeah log meal Jobs blacksmith's
apprentice he was a farmhand an amateur
opposite obstetrician used to deliver
babies in a factory oh my god it's a
real it's a potion he was like I'm doing
all these Brack bait back-breaking jobs
I want to taste that good life I want a
little piece of the pie babe the law at
this time is a little bit herky-jerky
anyone who could has a couple legal
terms really can make him a lawyer
so anyways Harlan's like I'm a lawyer
now this is what I do I wear suits I
have cool hair and so he takes his
client it's a nice juicy case and he's
fighting he's fighting habeas corpus
this will stay an object the judge says
you in Holland you got it in there I was
like yes they're high-fiving in the
forum like oh let's celebrate but first
I'm gonna take my cut and the guy is
like I'm not good with that let me have
the check push comes to shove literally
I push you you pushed me I pushed you
pretty soon they start punishing each
other in the courtroom yeah in the court
in the court is basically like dude
you're off the hook in terms of the
legal but you're done as a little lawyer
so he licks his wounds he's like I mean
I was just getting good at this so
sometime later he's like working on an
acid
this is agent he's like how can this gas
station become or how can you come here
slip your tank but get a little bite
while you're over here waiting start
putting chicken into a seasoning I've
got all 11
herbs and spices in a pressure cooker to
make it more juicy and more special and
more delicious
finally at 65 he reached his pinnacle it
is like I'm gonna open this place I'm
Colonel Sanders and this is Kentucky
Fried Chicken
[Music]
yeah we've never like done something
just for money you know no that's cool